it is the sweetest equation ever i love
it
[Music]
what's going everyone i've got a super
special podcast video for you today
um what i want to talk to you about is
how
um to answer the hardest questions in
business using one
math equation that only has three
variables all right and don't worry
it's like it'll be worth it this is the
number one thing this is the number one
equation that i use in my entire life
all right uh for business it's the one
that i use most frequently
and where this all started for me was um
i remember when i had my gyms which is a
recurring revenue business
obviously um i just i wanted to know how
we were doing
but you know my data tracking wasn't
great and
and i you know it's just like stuff was
all over the place and i just didn't
know how what we were doing and what we
were on track for
and i just know how it worked and i was
like man i wish i could just like see
into the future i wish i knew
what this would end up like right and so
i was uh playing around with math stuff
and this is actually at a time when i
was trying to get better at math because
i'm not i wasn't naturally good at math
um and so i would just like try and like
write out what like how i would try and
calculate this and i really struggled
with it
and one day i was driving and it
actually just hit me i was like what if
i just divided it by this
and that would just tell me the number
and it turns out i was right
and so what i want to explain to you is
the number one equation that i use the
most
in all of business and i call it
the pi equation all right now it has
nothing to do with pi
p i right um and it has everything to do
with any kind of just i mean really just
all business it is
the sweetest equation ever i love it i
use it all the time all right
so what is the pi equation why is it
called pi um i actually think i was
dieting at the time so i called it pie
because it looked like a pie when i drew
it out
pie like the pie you eat no actual real
reason i call it this
and for some reason it has stuck all
right and so it is a simple equation it
is a division
equation all right very simple draw a
big line here all right
and what it essentially is i'll draw a
smaller one here just so you can see it
is inflow divided by
outflow all right so why is this useful
so for me i like to have a very good
idea of where my business is at where
they're growing whether we're shrinking
what if we just did this for the rest of
a year
or forever what we'd end up at and that
is exactly what this question answers
what's important about this is that the
inflow is
actually a rate thing so basically
you're dividing rates to get an outcome
all right
i'm not going to get like super into it
uh because that's not what's important
what's important is understanding what
it will give you which is your
hypothetical max
right and it gives you three different
hypothetical maxes
uh so you can calculate stuff for your
business all right so
for example let's say i have an inflow
of
five new customers per month all right i
get five new customers a month
and let's say that my churn on my
membership am i recurring my service
whatever
right is let's say it's ten percent all
right so that's point
one ten percent all right so if i wanna
know
what the max amount of customers i will
be able to have given this inflow
i can project that so right now if i
have let's say
30 clients if i'm doing this and getting
five new clients a month and losing 10
percent
it means that i will be growing because
10 of 30 would be
three and i'm getting five right but at
some point
in the future right as i go on there
will be a point where ten percent is
equivalent to five and at that point i'd
reach equilibrium
and so that is when i would have reached
my hypothetical max
and so why this is so important is that
when i do this little equation let's say
it's
5 divided by 0.1 which is 50 right
which means 50 is going to be my
hypothetical max
so i know that if i'm signing up five
people every month
and i'm losing 10 of my clients every
month that i will
reach a business that has 50 clients on
average and i will not be able to
increase that number ever unless
i either increase the amount of people i
sign up the rate at which i sign them up
or i decrease the rate at which people
leave
and that's it pretty cool right like
this equation has like changed my life
so what it does is it allows me to make
very quick uh calculations to understand
where i'm at whether we're doing well
whether we're shrinking etc so for
example
if we had the same equation where i said
i had 30 people right now
and i said i'm signing up two people a
month right
and i've got 10 churn then i know that
the hypothetical max of that
is 20 right is 20 which means
that i'm going to be shrinking from 30
to 20 over the next how many months
unless i fix this
and so it gives me a very clear snapshot
of what
whatever i'm currently doing
extrapolates into the future
now you probably already have some ideas
of how you could use this in your
business right
this gives you a hypothetical max it
projects out your current rate
so you can understand where you're going
that's the point
all right now let me draw a little
dotted line here
that is the first use of this equation
the second use is understanding lifetime
value
all right so let's say that we have a
client
and the average revenue per client that
we have per month
let's say is uh 500 all right
so let's say it's let's use a different
number let's say a thousand dollars all
right that's a little simple
all right so a thousand dollars per
month is my average
revenue per client now
let's say that i can keep a thousand
dollar per month client
uh for five months so my churn right the
percentage that would leave every month
would be 20
all right so 20 which would be 0.2 right
is my rate of people leaving 20 of my
customers so if i have 10 customers 2
leave every month it's 20
all right let's churn now when i phrase
the equation or whatever when i
when i frame it this way i can now
extrapolate how much this person is
worth to me
so if i know that my average person pays
me a thousand a month and i know that on
average 20
of my customers leave every month then i
know that my customers aren't average
worth five thousand dollars which is 1
000 divided by 0.2
pretty sweet right so now i know that if
all customers that come to me if i
change nothing are worth five thousand
dollars
then that gives me a number that i can
go and market with i know that i can
spend at least a thousand two thousand
dollars
to go acquire this customer right i'm
using rough math it'd be less than two
thousand you want to be
a three to one i'm not going to get into
that right now but that's that's the
point here is that this would give me
rough math to know how much i could
spend to acquire a customer
that's super useful now
with these two things together i can
know
where my business is going to stall i
can also see how i can manipulate these
uh variables in order to know
where my business is going to reach now
i can also see if i'm
increasing if i'm if i'm growing my
business or if i'm
my business is shrinking simply by
knowing what my inflow of customers in
versus my outflow
now you can also do this on a bigger
scale
i said it's it's three variations of the
same concept all right
now let's say i'm signing up ten
thousand dollars a month of new business
all right
so this is the same concept as this what
i was talking about over here where
you know i'm signing up five customers a
month but this is just basically
combining the first two things into one
overall number
right so i'm signing up ten thousand
dollars a month of new business
all right that's what i'm setting up in
new business per month
all right now if i know that i'm losing
again 10 of my revenue per month
then i know that's 10 percent oops which
is 0.1
right or 0.1 then i know that this
business
is going to cap out at 100 000
per month now again the reason that
that's important and the reason that i
use all three of these variations of
this equation
is because i can see if i'm shrinking or
i'm getting bigger if i know that we
signed up ten thousand dollars
uh in a month and we're doing 10 turn
and we're we're
i know we're going to extrapolate out to
a hundred thousand dollars a month but
if we're currently at 200 i'm like
that's not good we need to fix something
or if we're at 50 i'd be like that's
awesome we're going to double
but the thing is is that you're going to
double and then you're going to cap
and what's more is that
as you do this unless you have negative
churn which most people do not have in
service-based businesses
what's going to happen is that your rate
of growth is going to slow all right so
it looks like this
all right and so this is going to be
your hypothetical max
right at the top here all right and so
what happens is you quickly like when
you have zero clients when you sign up
10 people
right boom you have a huge explosion in
growth right percentage-wise it's like a
vertical line
right but the next month when you have
ten and you lose two now you have eight
but then you gain another ten
but you only gained eight right but then
now you lose ten percent again
right so you lose or sorry twenty
percent again but now you lose three
because ten percent is bigger of 18
right so you drop down to 15 but then
you add another 10
right but now you're at 25 but you
notice how the rate goes from 10
to 8 to 2 to 7
right the growth continues to slow down
over time because
churn eats out a bigger and bigger
percentage right and so
with this you can know that this is
going to be your hypothetical max
realistically though most businesses
have enough volatility that once you're
at about 80 90
of your max which would be like right
here right it's realistically where
you'll
usually end up capping out because your
your your fluctuations in business are
such that
that's around where you're going to be
now i'm going to add in a bonus thing
for you which is called the golden ratio
and so the golden ratio is the way to
beat this equation so that you actually
never end your growth
here's how it works
we're gonna have two rates so you have
the rate of people leaving
right leaving percentage you can put
that as whatever you want
fancy word is turn leaving percentage
x's percentage cancel percentage
whatever
and then here you have your referral
percentage
this is where things get magical so
if 10 of your customers were to refer a
new customer every month
and five percent of your customers leave
every month
then you have 10 percent
over 5 percent and it means
that your business will double every
growth period sorry it uh
basically it just it will continue to
unendingly grow because the more people
who come in
from referrals a smaller percentage
leave every month and this
is called net negative churn this is
where you have a business
that grows faster than it turns on its
own without paid advertising because
your product is so
good that is where we all want to go
this is the promised land
this is the golden ratio which is what i
call it
and when you can achieve this you can
grow forever
now re realistically you don't grow
forever because you'll get big enough
and you'll mess something up and then
all of a sudden your referral
percentage will go down or your turn
percentage will go up one of those
things happen but when you can achieve
this for a period of time
that is when you have crazy growth right
because not only are you getting
customers
from your normal acquisition channels
but you're actually the percentage of
customers who refer
which is why it's important uh is it
stays fixed and it's greater than your
percentage turn and so it just continues
to grow and grow and grow
which is awesome um so as a quick recap
for you
the pi equation is the most used
equation that i use in all of business
especially if you have a recurring
revenue based business but even if you
do not
it's still an awesome equation and i use
it in three specific ways
one is so that i can know whether i'm
growing or shrinking number one
number two i used to extrapolate out
what my current
uh my group acquisition versus my
outflow rate
how much i'm going to level out at
this equation gives me that answer to
the same degree it also gives me my
hypothetical lifetime
value per client so i can know that how
much i can spend
to acquire customer because i can know
exactly what they're going to be worth
to me given their churn and what they
pay me on average per month
and again i can put all those things
together into one number where i say i'm
starting up this much new business per
month
and this much business lose is leaving
and this is going to be my overall
number this top number
is going to be the overall number that
i'm going to be able to generate
per month in my business all right um
and so putting all these things together
is i use this equation
i mean i five times a day i use it all
the time i use it when i'm coaching
people i use it when i'm thinking about
how we're doing
and this is the type of back and neck
and math that i feel like every
entrepreneur needs to have
in order to be able to understand where
their business is and how it's doing
and let me show you one more way to use
this because like i said i use this
question
literally every day all the time
and it's by combining two of those
pieces so if i had
like i said earlier let's say i had five
thousand dollars was the lifetime value
right that i had calculated
right which was based off of uh you know
a thousand dollars per month
uh divided by uh 20 churn
right that gives me my 5 000 now
let's say that i know that i'm signing
up 20 clients a month
i can know that simply by these two
numbers if i know what my inflow is 20
clients a month
and i know that they're going to be
worth five thousand dollars total
then i know that my business is going to
level out at a hundred thousand dollars
per month
all right this is like the biggest thing
ever
this is how this like the whole game
works like this is the equation this is
how
everything that i extrapolates off of
this thing all right and so
20 right per month now here's where it
gets tricky because you're like well
that makes sense it's math yeah but it
doesn't look like that when you're in it
because when you're in it you sign up 20
customers and you're at
a thousand dollars a month per customer
you're doing 20 000 a month
and you don't know if you're doing well
or not because you don't can't see into
the future
to see that if you just keep doing what
you're doing and you don't break it and
you don't get entrepreneurial add and
you don't get shiny object syndrome if
you just
keep doing what you're doing and every
month you drop another 20 in
right you drop another 20 and you drop
another 20 in then you're going to get
to 100 000
a month right it takes time for
recurring revenue businesses to gain
traction
and so if you understand this it can
give you kind of this peace of mind and
understanding where you're going
where you're at whether you're growing
whether you're shrinking and what you
need to do to fix it
because with these equations you can say
either i have to increase the lifetime
value
i have to by either increasing the price
or decreasing the churn which is one of
those two things
or i have to increase my inflow and
simply by understanding those three
pieces
piece number one which is your price
piece number two which is your turn
piece number three which is your inflow
if you understand those three pieces
then you can understand exactly how to
make your business
however big you want so that is the pi
equation this is the most used equation
that i use i wish i could have a sexier
title for this
because everyone needs to watch it and
understand it in absolute depth because
this
is everything when i when i talk to a
business owner when they're struggling
when they don't know what to do
this is what i use this is it like this
is what i use when i'm trying to figure
out what their business i'm like what's
your inflow
what's your turn what's your average
price per user it's the first thing i'm
asking literally it's the first two
questions i'll ask
and then i'm like what's your revenue
right now and just by knowing that i can
know whether they're growing whether
they're shrinking how fast they're
growing i can know where they're going
to level out
i can know how many customers they're
going to level out at
i can know all of these things simply by
asking
those four pieces of of of data and
having this equation
in my back pocket and so i use this
every day
it's like i breathe this equation and
the more you play with it the more you
understand it
uh the more powerful you be as an
entrepreneur and i promise you it will
be worth mastering
so anyways hope you enjoyed this
hopefully uh
you like this uh leave a review for
you know the podcast or if you're
watching this on youtube leave a nice
review subscribe all that kind of stuff
otherwise keeping amazing rooting for
you and
talk to you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you